i feel really good in the happiest of
being here ed sheeran is a dad
the 29 year old singer and his wife
cherry seabourn
welcomed their first child together
after a totally secret pregnancy
yeah i know that was a surprise ed took
to instagram tuesday to share the news
about their sweet baby girl
posting this pic of some itty-bitty
socks
alongside the caption quote last week
with the help of an amazing delivery
team
cherry gave birth to our beautiful and
healthy daughter
lyra antarctica seabourn sheeran
cute and it gets even cuter the grammy
winner went on to gush about his new
life as a dad
saying quote we are completely in love
with her
both mom and baby are doing amazing and
we are on cloud nine over here
ed wrapped it all up asking fans for a
little privacy
sending lots of love and adding that
he'll see
everyone again when it's time to come
back
of course ed has always been super
private about his personal life
i don't know it was weird it was weird
for me weird for me in july 2019
he finally confirmed he was married to
cherry during an interview with
charlemagne the god
i'm constantly wake up every day with
cherry and i'm just like why the [ __ ]
are you with me like you could be
you'd literally be with who whoever you
wanted you've choked and you've chosen
me and
like i'm saying all of the things i
think are wrong with me but you still
want to be with me and i just find that
amazing the couple reportedly tied the
knot at his country estate in
england before christmas in 2018.
is she related you should have won yeah
i feel really good about that ed popped
the question
in january 2018 and announced the news
on instagram with this sweet shot
writing quote got myself a fiancee just
before new year
we are very happy and in love yeah she
was the year below me in high school
from the age of 11.
yeah the two have known each other since
they were kids something he talked to
e.t about
back in 2017. i think it's cool you know
you
you don't you don't get away with a lot
you don't get away with a lot because
you know she can call you out on
anything that same year the singer said
he was
all about starting a family one day i
wanted to be a dad like
last year i'm i'm i'm ready i'm ready
let's
let's go let's get going let's go yeah i
wouldn't yeah a toolbar toolplus babies
do you know like little fat
chubby babies that just kind of walk
around and end noted that when the time
comes
he plans to take a little break from
music to help raise the kiddos
when they hit sort of like four or five
and start primary school i'm just out
i think springsteen took an extended
break when when he when his kids like
went to school i think
i think that's going to be me i think
just uh i want to set up a little studio
in the countryside which i have done
and just have new artists come down
write songs with beautiful for people
[Music]